In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion, for May 7th, on which we commemorate the appearance of
the precious and life-giving cross over Jerusalem in 351.
On the 7th of the month, we celebrate the appearing in the sky over Jerusalem of the sign
of the precious and life-giving cross.
On the 7th of May in 351, the Day of Pentecost, in the reign of Constance and the Episcopate
of St. Cyril, there appeared in the sky over Jerusalem at the 3rd hour an immense and
shining cross that stretched from Golgotha to the Mount of Olives.
Its radiance was such that it surpassed the rays of the Son.
All the people, both young and old, ran to the Church of the Resurrection to raise hymns
of thanksgiving to God for this miracle that manifested the glory of the cross and
its victory over the powers of darkness.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.